Chilling down stairs, right...
and.. like, just out of nowhere i hear a big bang.
(boom)
upstairs, right
I don't know what it is, cause I'm home alone
so... if there is actually something here..
Then i am scared...
here hold on let me see.
♫ if you came here to kill me clap your hands ♫
*cLAP clAP*
Meme review, everybodyyy[yEs]
Youtube's favorite show![duh]
*running in distinct*
(music plays)
SPECIAL NEWS ANNOUNCEMENT!
Good evening.
My name is Gloria Borger.
I work for meme review now.
Doin' the special new coverage of memes,
and your- whatever you need to know about memes.
THIS JUST IN, last week Neck Man
very large neck, look at that neck
I'm sorry but
do you see dat necc
very big neck man was arrested
but it turns out he made a friend.
I love when news are wholesome.
I know I'm not supposed to give my own opinion, but
this is a beautiful thing. (ikr)
Wide neck, meets up with long neck.
It's the Ying, and the Yang.
Wide necc and long necc
perfectly balanced,
as all things should be.
Ah, you don't want no smoke.
Where dat n!bba daddy long necc at?
Imma beat his @ss, yeah imma snap his @ss
*they met eachother!*
tight 'em up, lets go
hand shakeu
(lmao loading)
all necks matter!
*sweet music plays*
yeee slide UwU
Big necc koala wit Parrot long necc
rUN forest run
*hand shakeu again*
seems fun yeee
WOsh
Pewds is thinking
ALL NECKS MATTER!
I'm not supposed to have my own opinion on meme review,
but smash like if you agree with dis message.
I mean I'm not supposed to have my own opinion,
but this seems like the most ambitious anime crossover
since the Lion King.
I mean just look at these two,
how can you not love them?
(pop)
I mean (clap clap)
Next news comes from stairs,
That's right everybody.
Last week we covered stairs.
Scientistshave debated for so long,
for centuries, for eons.
What is the most effective way to go upstairs?
Do you walk one step at a time,
or do you walk two steps at a time?
Let's look at climbing stairs, and how much pow-
Blah, blah, blargh! Pseudoscience,
Don't waste my time.
Everyone know it goes like this
One step at a time, bunch of virgin losers.
Two steps at a time, you're slightly better.
Three steps at a time,
Ahhhhh!
You're an absolute Chad.
Sixteen steps at a time, you're practically god. [nAni]
But what scientists now...
from carefully studying the data
has now revealed that the ultimate way
to walk up the stairs...
revealing first time, live, here on meme review
as Gloria Borger is to crawl up the stairs!
You're not alpha, unless you crawl up the stairs everybody.
(epic music plays)
Next. (clap) News. (clap)
Next news comes from Florida.
Florida, which is of course the most insane place in the world where you get the best headlines.
Florida man accused of attacking girlfriend with banana. [wt]
Okay
Florida man forced to...
Suck...
Or...
Does...
Or now incoming new Florida Man!
Florida man claims he only drank at stoplight and not while driving.
Now, I'm not supposed to have my opinion
but god bless you Floyd le Fluer
God bless you.
(clap, clap)
That was it for Gloria Borger.
Let's begin meme review.
(laughing)
(pew news theme plays)
(musik)
♫ yeah ♫
♫ ay ♫
♫ it's the thirst, thirstiest time of the year ♫
♫ yeah, yeah ♫
♫ I have just one query ♫
They did surgery on a grape!
♫ the answer is clear ♫
♫ it's the thirst, thirstiest time of the year♫
♫ Sprite, let's go ♫
[wat?]
Apparently, this months meme decided to be the absolute worst and berry related
Coincidence? I DON'T THINK SO!
This is another corporate shill,
paying their ways into memes
and I'm not buying it.
I'm not buying it Sprite!
Oh they got Suzumiya Haruhi.
God fruckin damnit!
DRAH!
This is multilayered marketing, you understand that right?
Girlfriend, has mood swings
Sprite Cranberry, has no emotions
Girlfriend, can't touch her without...
Uh...
Girlfriend, LeBron doesn't even know her!
sponsored by...okay.
But like, what does it taste like?
But does it taste like cranberry?
Cause I kinda want to try it now.
NO!
If you wanna waste your money,
then buy the PewDiePie merch.
Link in the description.
None of this cranberry.
You've stranded in the desert, it's 100 degrees
you have no water, as you begin to fade away
he reaches out to you.
Want a Sprite Cranberry?
I feel like I have not explained this meme, really.
It's just this stupid commercial,
with LeBron James going, "You want a Sprite Cranberry."
That's it.
I don't know if you expected any...
Okay, that's kinda funny
(Pewds laughing)
No I don't LeBron James, no I freakin' don't.
Stop asking me.
Please
Despite how absolute trash this meme is
That's right I called it trash.
There are some good ones out of it.
Like LeBron James breaking into your
house to offer you Sprite Cranberry...
ASMR
(knocking)
Want a Sprite Cranberry?
Sprite (knock, knock, knock) Cranberry
(pounding) Want a Sprite Cranberry?
(knocking) The answer is clear.
No I don't!
Lebron, oh my god!
Want a Sprite Cranberry?
The answer is cle-
Jesus Christ Lebron
Now I know what you're all thinking.
Does it actually taste like Cranberry?
Well, I have not tried it
but I have Timothy Burmingham
Who is clearly before his time.
With three years
drinking a sprite cranberry.
Let's see what he has to say.
Hey everyone.
How ya doin'
My name is Timothy
and I will be trying Sprite-
That's so much Sprite Cranberry
That is a lot of Sprite Cranberry
You cannot argue with that.
Cranberry
Yeah, Sprite Cranberry.
Alright so what do you got for us Timothy?
What does it taste like?
It's got a pinky taste, I know that.
That's for sure.
What does it taste like Timothy?
Well let's see I gotta rate this...
Yes! Please rate it!
What are you rating it Timothy?
I gotta rate it
Please Timothy!
Oh my god Timothy!
A three
A three! A three, it gets a three
The Sprite Cranberry meme gets also a three.
Thank you Timothy Burningam.
Thank you, arigato gozaimasu
Cranberry!
Did you know they did surgery on a grape?
(laughing)
Introducing a new segment on this show, again
New meme format
We announce new meme format.
What is this meme, I don't know.
What does this meme
(laughing)
Global warming, humanity
My grades, me
That's relatable.
When you finally catch that mother fu- ck
That's been holding you down.
Introducing a new meme segment everybody.
This one is called not quite ready to die, that's right.
Too early to kill 'em.
We have Moyai
that's right, the Easter island emoji